والله الوضع في الاندونيسي صعب جدا ايش
كان والله حصروتي حوالينا والله اكثر من
25 واحد شهير انا نقلتهم بايدي اقسم بالله
ماتوا من قله الادويه والعلاجات كيف كانت
الطريقه صعبه صعبه جدا اشنا والله صعبه
تفتيش وتصور تعال يا ف ويتك واطلع يا فلان
اسئله مش عارفين احنا وين رايحين احنا
والله مده اسبوع او ع ايام يمكن اكثر انا
شبه فاقد الوعي لان نزلت عن الطبق الثاني
لقيت حدا على الارض الدار نزلت طبعا ود
استشهدوا
اثنين وفي اصابات برضه في
البيت وامور صعبه والله جدا للغايه نزحنا
من هذاك خلينا رحت على دار اهلي الاولاد
يعني ابني قبل هيك تصاوب وكنت اخذته على
المستشفى العوده عشان اغيرله على راسه ا
20 غرزه الدار ست طوابق نزلت وخشت على
الدار وطنا من تحت الركام هذا الطفل وكان
يعني عنده حروق هيها يعني حروق
شديده سيء جدا سيء للغايه مافيش نظافه فيش
عنايه كارثه
بالنسبه رعب يعني المنطقه حوالينا يعني
بصراحه الضرب
حوالي
m